Our next important
concept is the matching.
Given a graph,
a subset of the edges is a matching
if no two edges share a vertex.
Note that the graph doesn't
have to be bipartite.
Take for example, this graph here.
These two edges here
constitute a matching.
By the way, we'll refer to an edge
in a matching as a matched edge so
these two edges are matched.
And we'll refer to a vertex in
a matched edge as a matched vertex.
So these four vertices
here are matched vertices.
A maximum matching or
max matching, for short is
a matching of maximum cardinality.
Note that a maximal matching
is not a maximum matching.
For instance,
this matching here is maximal
because I can't add any more edges and
still have it be a matching.
On the other hand,
it's not maximum because there's
a matching of greater cardinality.
For instance, this one here.
This happens in bipartite graphs too.
Here is a maximal matching but
it's not maximum because
there is a greater matching.